well they've been announced by the
Metropolitan Police in a pretty lengthy
statement which was issued at five
o'clock that was an hour and a half
after Rishi sunak finished answering
questions from the liaison Committee of
senior MPS which of course is chaired by
Sir Bernard Jenkin now the key bits of
the long statements I'll read you are
that's a video we've just seen relates
to an event on the 14th of December uh
2020 in Tory HQ and regarding that the
Metropolitan Police have said this
following assessment of new evidence
that was not previously provided to
officers the Met is now reopening an
investigation into potential breaches of
the regulations at an event in Matthew
Parker Street on the on the 14th of
December 2020 and then in the next
sentence uh the of the statement it
talks about an event on the 8th of
December 2020 now that is a gathering
that took place in the rooms of Dame
Eleanor Lang who is a senior Deputy
speaker in the House of Commons and Sir
Bernard Jenkin who is not only chairman
of the liaison committee but was one of
the MPS on the Privileges committee
which found that Boris Johnson had
misled MPS over partygate
on that gathering this the Met says this
following assess of material relating to
a gathering in Parliament the Met is
opening an investigation into potential
breaches of the regulations at an event
on the 8th of December 2020 well in the
last few minutes we've heard from the
speaker's office sir Lindsay Hoyle and
Sir Lindsay hoyle's office has told Sky
News as uh as the as this is a live as
this is a live investigation any further
inquiry should be made to the
Metropolitan Police now
sir Bernard has told a journalist it's
not appropriate to comment on a
continuing investigation
now Sky News understands that Dame
Eleanor Lang Deputy speaker who was away
from Parliament earlier this year uh
with due to illness and uh so
um the sir Roger Gales stepped into a
deputize she uh I understand is not
stepping aside whilst this investigation
goes on
um but uh clearly this is uh quite a
Twist in the whole row over party gate
and of course there has been criticism
of Sir Bernard once this were gathering
in day Melina's office was first
reported she has previously said it was
a business meeting it was all socially
distanced uh sir Bernard has never
denied attending the events it was due
it was said to be uh uh to mark his wife
Anne's birthday another conservative MP
who attended Virginia Crosby has since
apologized for uh attending but of
course the the context of all this is
that supporters of Boris Johnson are
furious with sir Bernard because of his
role on the Privileges committee and
said
Boris Johnson and indeed his leading
supporters like uh that's uh Jacob Reese
mogg have said that sir Bernard should
have stepped down as chairman of the
liaison committee well he did not he
today chaired that committee uh went on
for 90 minutes subjects included uh the
cost of living small boats uh and so on
a lot of Mr sunax five priorities and
there was also a furious clash between
uh sir Chris Bryant's and the prime
minister in which Chris accused uh the
prime minister of dodging Parliament the
votes on privileges Owen Paterson and uh
and uh and also uh Boris Johnson and uh
uh criticizing for not announcing his uh
his uh health care plan uh in Parliament
on Friday and also we learned that the
PM is missing
um prime minister's questions tomorrow
because of NHS celebrations and also so
next week because of a NATO Summit and
also Chris criticized the PM for missing
prime minister's questions as well